- What's up y'all.
I'm back with Mike Epps and Wanda Sykes.
Give it up!
(audience cheering and clapping)
So Wanda and Mike have
a new sitcom on Netflix
called the Upshaws.
And over the years sitcoms have brought us
dozens of awesome
one-liners and catchphrases
that I really hope I remember right now.
But how well do Wanda and I know
which catchphrase comes
from which sit-com.
It's time to find out with a game called
Yabba dabba do you know the show?
♪ Yabba dabba do you know the show? ♪
- We're clever here.
- Yabba dabba doo, do you know the show?
- Here's the actual best part.
I literally didn't know
what Yabadabadoo was from.
And my.
- What?
- Yeah, so I'm gonna do well at this game.
I didn't know.
I didn't watch the Flintstones.
Don't tell anyone, I know.
Mike Epps has graciously agreed to host
since I don't even know
what Yabba dabba do is.
So tell us how the game works, Mike.
- Okay, this is how the game goes.
Yabba dabba doo.
It's simple Kelly.
I'm gonna read a phrase, a famous phrase
from a classic sit-com
and you and Wanda will hit the button
to say the name of the show.
- Okay.
- All right.
- I feel like I'm gonna do better
than not knowing the title.
- Yabba dabba doo then. (indistinct)
Okay.
If you wrong, the other
person can steal it.
Okay.
- Okay.
That's how it's gonna go.
Okay.
Wanda's playing from the
right side of the audience
and Kelly, you playing from the left side.
And the winner gets a prize for her side.
- Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Alright. First catch phrase is,
"How you doing?"
(buzzer dings)
- How you doing?
Joey Tribbiani "Friends."
(bell dings)
(Kelly screams happily)
Oh my God I feel good.
I'm very competitive.
Let me just warn you.
- Okay that was pretty good.
This ones a bit hard Wanda, Kelly, okay?
"That's what she said!"
- That's "The Office."
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Man, Wanda (indistinct) that one.
Here we go, here we go.
The next one is,
"Did I do that?"
(buzzer dings)
- Steve Urkel, "Family Matters."
(bell dings)
- Dang it!
(Kelly screams)
- That was smoking, okay
The next one.
"They killed Kenny you bastards."
(buzzer dings)
- South Park.
(bell dings)
- Oh my.
[Kelly] I don't, I can't.
In fairness
- You know what, I'll play with one hand.
I'm just gonna do it with one.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh man, okay, okay.
- With the same energy all the time.
"What'd you talking about Willis?"
(buzzer dings)
- "Diff'rent Strokes."
- Anyway, I know the song
can play that game dammit.
- You sound pretty good.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
The next one.
- She's quick
"No soup for you."
(buzzer dings)
- That's Seinfeld.
- Oh my.
(bell dings)
- No soup for you, next in line please.
- Well that's a pretty, I know that one.
I've seen that show.
- Okay Wanda
you dominating but it
looks like she trying
to come back
- She trying to come back.
- Okay (laughs).
- "Dynomite!"
(buzzer dings)
- Good times.
- I feel like we're
(indistinct) the same time.
- Good times.
- We might need to play the camera back
to see who hit it first.
- She's quick.
Okay.
I haven't watched a few
weeks, this is hard.
(horn honking)
- Oh, that sound means
this is the last question.
The ones worth five points.
- Oh.
- What?
- Yeah, this is where I come in.
- The last one
- I'm ready.
- D O,
Doh.
(buzzer dings)
- That's Homer Simpson.
The Simpsons.
- Now what the hell
just happened?
(bell dings)
- That was not fair.
- Come on Wanda, run.
- What!
He just said DO.
I was like, "What!"
I would've gotten Doh.
I would've gotten.
- I'm sorry.
The host was a GD
- You teamed up, its fine.
- The host need a GD, man.
(every one laughs)
- I was like DO?
And then she got it before I knew it.
She still got it.
Okay, the winner is
Wanda that's so amazing.
You know what, you stay over there DO.
That means that all the right side
of the house seats wins a prize.
And it's my show.
So you win as well left side.
You're welcome.
Our friends at Life is Good
are on a mission to inspire
people to choose optimism
to positively impact their
lives and the lives of others.
And they do this through
positive art and messages
on a broad variety of
apparel, partnership products,
and most importantly,
an ever-growing community
of inspiring optimists.
Everyone in the house seats
is getting a $300 gift
card to Life is Good.
(audience cheers and claps)
And since Wanda won so fairly,
her photo will be mounted,
she would've beat me anyway.
Her photo is gonna be mounted
on the Blake Shelton wall of champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
So damn you all.
- I'm honored.
Yes.
It's only, there's only a few Wanda.
Okay.
There's a lot, whatever.
Be sure to check out Wanda and Mike
and their new show, "The
Upshaws" on Netflix right now.